glad to see you again the show is going
to start in a second but for people who
don't yet know or haven't yet joined
please do consider joining my club at
ladders credit.com slash mug club you
get this wonderful hand etched mug
girthy and you get access to like 80%
more content along with access to the
entire blaze catalog that's a lot of
credit calm slash mug Club at $69 for
students veterans active military and
it's the only one we keep the lights on
we are not monetized on YouTube it is
entirely funded by viewers like you
and not a foreign caliphate just mugs
for those who have not yet joined up
here's a little bit of what you missed
this week I'll pacino piano it's only
one note I love this episode it's it's
how you make lemonade from all
depictions of Tim family must be treated
with the same reverence as the men
themselves which is why we've made this
recent addition to our company
restaurant I like to Pete on the lips
and not actually into the mouth Grif is
actually the gentleman I spoke about in
the close one time at the the gym I want
to see your thoughts so you can see this
is what's airing right now on television
let's also not forget someone in the
trans community I absolutely would cover
the right to have an abortion people
really discussing it debate that wasn't
the presidential debate trick devious
[Music]
lahter with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
[Music]
now where are the other two the half
Asian one well we looked everywhere sir
I mean ma'am I mean observer mind it
doesn't matter
have you read our new Community
Guidelines yet yes sir but they're uh
they're a little confusing or contradict
already broken most of them audio Wade
you desecrated the Dan Fogelberg saw but
congratulations you are actually the
least offensive of the bunch
quarterblack Garrett I know you've taken
part and some of the most racist
sketches ever uploaded to this platform
fat drunken quarter black is no way to
go through life sub and mr. Crowder the
reason we had to rewrite our Community
Guidelines in the first place
there is literally not a single
marginalized group that you haven't
insulted we've even had to create new
groups just because of you a fine
example you've set now make sure you
tell the half asian and then the wine
guy exactly what I'm about to tell well
what was that sir
you're out finished at YouTube D
platformed I want you off this channel
Monday morning and I'm sure they'll be
happy to know I've contacted Facebook
and Twitter as well also LinkedIn tick
tock slack Spotify you won't be able to
so much as open them myspace account
well well
out with it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that is called me laughs room had the
scenes that we introduced to children
having my lawyer assassinated what a
wonderful good job to the show hey that
reminds me a guest today we'll be
talking about Pete but gig whether he's
a moderate candidate and that's a
question today
have you heard him referred to as a
moderate candidate Pete but dick of
Indiana and do you think that they're of
enemy have been any truly moderate
Democrats since 2000 I don't know
whatever yeah and I realize I just meant
to say any moderate but I said dammit in
a sound like I said seeing them and he's
really that's an actual thing I don't
know reminds me my lawyer
as you see dies horribly but today we
have he predicted Mike Tyson Jeffrey
Epstein Harvey Weinstein recently Donald
Trump America's favorite lawyer Alan
Dershowitz is here but first oh wait a
second before we get to that half a
similar bill Richman how are you feeling
wonderful glad to be here quarterblack
gear we're using great yeah I don't I
don't want to see it audio AG Morgan Jr
what's your one one of the day is born
of fire Cabernet okay well next time you
can serve it to our audience members do
you realize that we just had no serve it
to our audience members and he refused
yeah I did yeah yeah I refuse service he
seems I can I have the right there's
like a nice guy but behind the scenes
he's a massive I don't serve white
people Stephen Moore right we move on to
nah we have to get to this
it's pretty high pick
for those listening on audio I'm sorry
but I that's up what people but I knew
that I knew it looked familiar
[Music]
walk out music feels like the voice is
gonna be really hurtin I say in 2020
like hey don't don't just scream out
casually how adults act you're an adult
it's awesome I love emotional you're not
dropping or you're Irish folk song
influenced single okay we'll also be
talking about Pete but get quite a bit
today and in Michael Bloomberg but
leading the news Bernie Sanders of
course was the winner of the New
Hampshire primary scored a slim victory
over former mayor Pete but gig and
Sanders now turns his attention to South
Carolina that's the big story of course
has been following it where he's gonna
have to shift gears people are talking
about this they took we don't talk about
political strategy holdout in the show
but he's going to need to appeal and
he's been trying to more traditionally
religious voters
[Music]
hey Christ would you do it unfasten
Bernie you know if you were to endorse
me for leader of the free world everyone
could be fasting a little time believe
me I know Jesus I'd like you to think
about joining me we can spread matching
uniforms and crippling taxes across the
world you mean stealing democratic steel
so stealing I'm okay
I'm gonna go back to fast free health
care really yes I'm not interested in
any way look I've had enough I don't
want any very much so oh Jesus yeah if
you're truly God's Son and I'm not
saying you are not the angel
the son of man ringing it against Bernie
it's true everybody's against him the
Lamb of God clearly has a club which are
bent that's really a me also by the way
some some sad news to reply apologize
for this program for this America's
favorite lawyer sad news actually an
endangered wolf that walked 8700 mile
out to find a mate and love has died
this comes from The Guardian scientists
had been tracking the wolf since she
left Oregon for California in 2018 cross
country to find a mate they named her Oh
r54 which in Cherokee translates to
traveling [ __ ] wolf
oh well knows what she wants and she get
lost on the way eighty seven hundred
miles from Oregon to California you know
what horror wolves traveling or wolf
they're not going to respect you until
you respect yourself you just have to be
yourself it's enough it's enough
international news by the way the Swiss
they don't make the news a whole lot but
they voted to penalize public homophobia
now that's going to be a new law wasn't
before now they are protected which is
actually great news for Switzerland
number one favorite hot cocoa brand
Swiss mr. [ __ ] so that is process
cocoa no I'm a cacao fan really oh good
lord
and you know the differences nothing it
means I'm an ass I just say cacao
because I want to have the conversation
reason would even mean cocoa I said no
no cacao then I explained you the
different processing it just means you
should walk along your merry way and
avoid me at a party yes I did I do that
anyway I also paid too much for
groceries so a man was another news he
was arrested for trying to pay a
prostitute with a hamburger
Newsweek it may seem out of the ordinary
to some trying to pay for sex with a
hamburger but it's actually surprisingly
an increasingly common it happens quite
a bit so oh hey why macdonald team don't
even get me started on the Burger King
kids club
oh yeah the club you want to be a part
no no what is this it makes no sense
well and also for those listening on
audio do you remember grimace for kind
of central just you for those listening
on audio you're what you're listening to
a TV show but we still want you there
takeaway here is that Gerald isn't as an
ungenerous
yes he does what do you use pay with
McDouble no I pay with wine is do you
pay with wine yes okay that's about
everything good yeah I just boxed him
into a corner because I know his wife is
watching yeah Cheryl's like I just eat
Justin over here holds me nuzzle me you
large muzzle be nuzzle nuzzle thank you
by the way another story proving once
again that Internet is not real life
Andrew yang dropped out of the
presidential race cousin yeah man you're
doing so good your parents were almost
proud of me I just thought actually when
I saw the story I thought it was a new
hallmark film with Dean Cain Andrew yang
told supporters I'm not someone who
wants to take people's time and
dedication if I don't think we have a
chance to win so everyone here listen
obviously we look at these people it's
worthy competitors everyone here wishes
mr. yang well in his future endeavors of
course no ill will but for Andrew and
the yang gang it's time to close mr.
yang your ear signature policy is to
give
every adult in the United States $1,000
a month no questions asked that's right
and I think it's like three point two
trillion dollars a year how would you do
that
sorry time to close endings and
beginners are ending and the
[Music]
everything it's time to go to places
where you go to
[Applause]
Pizza guy
[Music]
[Applause]
you are getting
it's time to close
[Music]
shouldn't be doing jello shots all my
lawyer
it's like yeah I loved anything as much
as Andrew yang loved running for
president had a good time with it great
spirit also by the way a Tom step Tom
Steyer dropped out I just want to say
hyper yeah good okay
[Music]
that was that was Tom Styer you know we
all have different highlight reels
actually Shire didn't drop out actually
Michael Bennett yes when I tell the
story it's time stuff there's a 90%
chance yes so New York City Mayor Mike
Mike Bloomberg is actually now paint
this is a big store he's paying
influencers they make him seem cool Wow
this comes from The Daily Beast for a
hundred and fifty dollars the Bloomberg
campaign will pay people to say that
Mike Bloomberg is the most electable and
he's really trying to appeal to young
people don't remember this did you
receive the clip from the moves like
Bloomberg
[Music]
where it's please welcome counselor
black really just wants the Millennial
vote and it's it's not been working out
well for them we understand what he's
[Music]
you only have one Bloomberg no leave
$150 in the desk okay geez gotta get
paid even care about his politics or the
weird face it's just it's lazy writing
I thought you gonna say hi only has one
Bloomberg that's Malmberg you're just
trying to write it backwards I love it
I don't Louisiana Louisiana man how
about Pete butt-kicking alan dershowitz
spoiler again do you think Pete but gig
is a moderate candidate that's how
they're trying to sell them right now I
do not agree
a Louisiana may and in other news he's
been arrested and charged for burning
down three historically black churches
this comes from NPR he pled guilty to
all counts and was sentenced to five
years in historically black prison it's
that gonna go well yeah I think it's
more funny to me because it's the
theater of the mind yeah
yeah rape so finally my little pony
which I wouldn't wish on my worst enemy
except that guy My Little Pony and
Transformers have announced a crossover
yeah now this comes from comic book calm
because it's a slow news week so
Twilight Sparkle teams up with Optimus
Prime to overcome malevolent magic and
machinery the new series will be aptly
called trans ponies and they actually
have already signed the merchant we know
this it's all about merchandising
assigned the merchandising deal already
and we have an exclusive first look
[Music]
don't worry my little trick here you can
use whatever restroom you like my little
trick available exclusively at Target
they put all their eggs in the brick and
mortar bath it's working I have to admit
I was wrong I didn't think they were
positioned to connect it with Amazon and
Walmart yeah but I didn't see my little
pony coming down the pike in innovation
wins what am I in Oracle by the way our
trivia contest winner from last week who
is it their quarterback Garrett it is
Rebecca Patterson oh and she's one of my
favorite cigars Brickhouse standard
absolutely and I think we're about ready
[Applause]
station well know best your eyes it's
usually very taut it's been a long week
Hey I've been crying over my cousin
Andrew it's like underneath your eyes
can I put a pup tent called Kim jong-un
if we were commiserating together
underneath the under bags of your eyes
are like that tent that self-- pups in
the movie Congo parasite wins for the
meat segments
so this is what we'll be talking about
today you've been hearing this quite a
bit that Pete but gig I know I don't
care how it's pronounced that he is
moderate in the Democratic Party
everyone's been hearing this right this
is the attack they're trying to frame it
after after New Hampshire and after Iowa
right and it's this war between Sanders
and peak but gig Sanders is he's leading
in total votes but kick has slightly
more delegates well let's let's let's
let someone else tell you so that you
believe it you need 1991 delegates to
win the nomination this is the beginning
of a long road to that Democratic
convention in Milwaukee take a look at
where we are Buddha judge actually has a
to delegate lead at 23 Sanders 21 war
and 8 Clovis r7 Biden down at 6 so
Bernie Sanders very well emerges from
New Hampshire after a strong showing in
Iowa as the national front-runner with
this religious face but actually in the
way you get the nomination winning 1091
delegates it's big budda judge who added
these first two contests is actually out
you see he looks like you just saw the
Pillsbury Doughboy on his table
Paulito no just the kid from Christmas
Story what is that be so enthusiastic
it's bizarre to me oh my god we can
believe but that's okay
my reputation means not a thing pink has
told me I'm perfect who I am so just a
quick recap Iowa people didn't ask him
about the Iowa debacle I find it
incredibly boring there is an app made
by Democrats whose shadow Inc which had
only been around a couple of months to
calculate the results the app
malfunctioned and then we found out that
peak but gig made a victory speech even
though there were zero official results
which by the way good for you that's a
pimp move Pete but Giga actually respect
this like hey haven't now so I'm just
gonna say on the winner oh that's that's
illegal I don't really care yeah the
coin hunt told him yeah I'm gay if they
say I can't do it I'll to say it's a
hate crime and
oh my god I think it's I think it's a
reverse beard really yeah I think you
straightener great and just boring
I think he's straight yeah campaign
donate over 40,000 dollars to the app
company what and the Iowa Democratic
Party they were caught making errors
that strangely always seem to favor Pete
but giggle for Bernie so you can look
into it I understand what people think
that the deck may be stacked against
Bernie I'm not willing to confirm that
or say that I agree with you but I
understand why people might sort of
Express that sentiment so a lot of
Bernie bros thinks something's fishy
she's gone okay fine the dynamic here
now is that it's the socialist Bernie
Sanders versus this sort of centrist
that's what they're trying to create
with Pete but Kagan Bernie Sanders the
question really remains is but gig
actually a moderate you've been fed that
a whole lot
there's no way let's come down let's get
down to brass tacks let's go to let's
set with immigration okay immigration
economics and we'll get into more social
issues and I think half-asian bill is
uncomfortable that he had killed me
actually I'm just he's still dead I'm
just really I cannot I can just really
can't wrap my mind around that a group
that has always championed diversity is
going to be choosing between two white
males for may yeah that is one of them
is but one of them is gay sort of that's
why I think it'll be because activity
something right first black woman
Elizabeth Warren first woman Bernie
Sanders you know I don't know really
first president hens knowing but take a
look first first present first first
president and actually because we've had
a few memories a first president I mean
like sweeter that way you're just saying
like great Bernie will be the first
necklace president you know she's the
shoulders are always worse right I mean
it does you can just set the Cedars so
let me go ahead no no necklace
I was thinking you went on a cruise and
came back with those puka shells and
beads in his head no he said a little oh
eight a little break I don't think there
are belugas in the Saint Lawrence River
by the way I'm from under that we know
well it's three Pinocchio's canals and
rivers are not much I'm more I know a
lot about ravines you do you have a
question what ravines I'm your man it's
when it comes to the canals I'm about to
lunch so but gig well we talk about
immigration I think the first that we
has that we have it's on immigration
right yeah he says that there are 11
million illegals in the United States
and there's some there's some arguments
as to that number exactly right let's
use the number that he uses and he says
if they're 11 million illegals in the
United States though because the economy
brought them here and then he also
clarifies that or extrapolates that the
mission of ice is illegal they're you
know the reason we have 11 million
undocumented immigrants is because our
economy needed 11 million more people
then our system
waitwait was prepared to admit what so
another thing we got to do when we do
that reform is set it up so that in the
future you can review every couple of
years how many work based visas we need
to keep our economy going
okay let's clarify what Isis purpose is
okay it is to protect America from the
cross-border crime and illegal
immigration that threaten national
security and public safety so no P it's
not illegal they're quite literally
enforcing the most basic duty the United
States government in ensuring the safety
of our borders from people who could
potentially break the law and can't be
tracked and the reason that ice is
necessary and I know that there are lot
of people at the Young Turks and
Samantha bee who say it's a criminal
enterprise or they want you to think
about the Corleone's there's an honor
should be no it's criminal we already
have a police force but the reason ice
exists is because there are still
illegal immigrants there used to be in
record numbers now it's been decreasing
Thank You Donald Trump no commander
great I appreciate it I was wrong didn't
think you would win 2020 a landslide
please come on the show my point is
there was a reason that they exist that
they are necessary it's because the job
wasn't being done and we'll get to there
are some more reasons as to why that is
Pete but gig take it guess it involves
you first hit the notification bell if
you're watching this on youtube or leave
a review if you're listening on itunes
and do consider joining my club lot of
credit a comm slash Mudd Club you get an
entire show every day and access to the
whole blaze catalog along with some
additional content from Gerald and Bill
and uh Dave Rubin mm-hmm you know what I
respect Dave Rubin because he doesn't
side with Pete but geek it'd be very
easy would too you know that you have a
conclave of the gays role yes and they'd
be sending out behind clink smoke we'll
get back to immigration let's move on to
health care because a lot of people said
well he's moderate because he's not a
radical here's the thing when you're
comparing feet but gig to a radical
socialist who spent his honeymoon in the
USSR he spent his honeymoon in the
Zangief level and loved it I just want
to make a clear yeah you might see him
as a moderate but I think it's important
to compare him to all past Democrats
including Barack Obama Barack Obama
couldn't even see Pete but gig to his
left he's so far to the left of Barack
Obama so let's keep that in context
let's go to health care he's seen as a
moderate because he wants Medicare for
all who want it that's his plan that's
what he calls it and that's a
government-sponsored plan
to people who want it while letting
others keep the private insurance as
opposed to simply Medicare for all no
other option
yeah like Bernie Sanders so this is
really to be clear people don't
necessarily understand they say well it
seems more moderate than Bernie Sanders
okay short it's a public option just
like Obamacare but to a far more extreme
degree let me explain if you don't
enroll in in the insurance plan the
Medicare for all for those who want it
according to peg instead of just being
fined 695 dollars I think that's what it
was right under Obamacare 600 700 hours
November exactly you'll be Auto instead
of that you'll be automatically
registered if you don't have insurance
in the government program and you could
retroactively Leo as much as seven
thousand dollars in premiums at the end
of the year even though you never used
the insurance my gosh so you so it's
like for all who want it and if you
don't want it we're gonna pay seven
thousand dollars anyway why I thought
you said if I want it well and their
campaign is so out of touch with reality
that their staffers basically said well
it's not like you didn't have health
insurance the entire year you're just
paying for something that you had that
you didn't pay for before society's
gonna be happy but I didn't want it I
don't i doesn't matter I don't
understand the words that are coming out
of you I never used it well you could
have but I didn't want to you know I
guess you are stealing from me you say
tomahto I say $7,000 premium and it
doesn't end there by the way because we
go back to the illegal immigration so
you talk about this it's Medicare for
all who want it which really isn't an
option he wants to extend the
government-funded insurance know to
everyone including illegal immigrants
here you go
[Music]
I was talking about health care to
everyone in the country to allegedly
illegal immigrants she's saying
commodious a three-shot medicare for all
wanted speak but kate says that is our
solution and this opportunities to buy
this plan is for everyone regardless of
their immigration status see at least a
Spanish is better than Cory Booker
exactly just what I was thinking about
when I was watching its work oh my gosh
but not as good as as Andrew yang
Cantonese is a Cantonese I have no idea
don't care he's gone today's my note
right in the history books of the Asians
[Laughter]
just wanted to build a wall to block out
all the candidate so they just say when
you're not doing well you revert to what
you know I think you wanted to party for
a few months and have it funded by other
people mission accomplished yeah pretty
much great but think about this for a
second think about that you want to
create basically mandated they say it's
an option but you have taxpayer-funded
health care and then you want to extend
it to people who are not even citizens
and by the way do you see now the
problem was abolished an organization
like ice who are designed to prevent
illegal immigration while you are
simultaneously incentivizing it and you
are incentivizing it by the way let's be
honest Pete but kid you've never done
anything successfully yourself in your
own life you are incentivizing it by
footing the bill at the American
taxpayers expense yes expensive they
don't care about the American worker
people wonder why huh why the all of it
you've seen all these states that have
flipped over I was I don't think I've
ever been more wrong about anything in
my life when I said there's no way
Donald Trump wins mission yeah there's
no way because it was such a
working-class kind of Union state and
the unions were bought and paid for by
by obviously Democrats and then Hillary
Clinton just I mean just screwed it up
she did everything possible to lose them
it is remarkable to me but these people
don't feel represent
by you why because according to Bernie
Sanders mind you anyone making over
29,000 dollars a year would have to pay
more for this government-funded health
insurance program and so the American
taxpayer will be subsidizing illegal
immigrants according to their own words
it doesn't mean that the American
taxpayer the average American worker is
racist it doesn't mean that they hate
brown people it means that they don't
want to be forced into a health care
system what they don't want to be a part
of a lot of them like the private
insurance and they certainly don't want
to be forced to pay for people who have
no business being here in the first
place many of whom don't pay any taxes
and the ones with face tattoos are
animals not all them I want to be clear
I don't want you to settle Trump I'm
calling all Mexicans animals no no no
just go into the face tattoos hoodoo
gang initiations where they steal Grand
Jury knows it's very specifically ok so
let's move on to guns this is another
one and this is a really hard issue for
the left because you have a lot of
people look at Bernie Sanders he's from
Vermont it's as liberal as it's the
place of Ben and Jerry for crying out
loud and you don't even need a permit at
all to carry a gun open or concealed
they have the most liberal gun laws in
the country there are plenty of
Democrats who are still pro-second
amendment this is a real problem for the
Democratic Party
Pete butt-kick he signed off on all of
the Democrats most radical gun control
proposals and I want you to watch this
clip because it's very very telling in
his own words as to why he is so pro gun
control and sweeping constricting gun
control legislation closing the hate
loophole the Charleston or is that mean
old disarming I hate that domestic event
enacting red flag laws extreme risk
protection orders banning the sale of
assault weapons like what I carried in
Afghanistan we know what we have to do
the question is how do we make sure that
this time really is different because
every time we say this time is different
and all of the plants of course I think
my plan is the best so does everybody
else course all of them are multiplied
by zero if we don't actually get
something done and so this is not just a
question about policy this is
question about power there it is it's a
question about a power that's what it is
it's not about policy it's a question
about power because what would be more
empowering to a bloated bureaucratic
federal government than removing your
ability to say no at some point down
that's real what the second amendments
people understand they talk about a war
it's not it's not about a civil war and
of course I'm not advocating any kind of
civil unrest right now but what the
second that second amendment is truly
about right you have the First Amendment
you have the right to say whatever you
want
the Second Amendment allows you the
right to defend saying no well you're
gonna have to do this no you're gonna
have to pay for healthcare for a legal
immigrants no that's the second meant is
that or you're going to have to be
enslaved
take your pick name any corrupt
government throughout the history man we
act like we're some out beyond this
right yeah we act like we're somehow
beyond slavery goes on across the world
you have people across the modern
Western world who are jailed for jokes
yeah the Second Amendment allows hey
we're gonna take you to prison because
you made a joke no that's the express
purpose of the Second Amendment
that's why they talk about it being
about power something else that I think
is important here the hate loophole it's
sort of like what once I took him to war
he was in the military can you point me
to any soldier who's gone into battle an
ar-15 ever
hmm you're a shooter they're half asian
builders down like 15 so they're
carrying m16 or maybe they're carrying
an m60 but they're all carrying right
automatic or burst which are outside of
the exactly and that's pretty important
because they trace well the ar-15 is
very it's the same check it's the same
chassis is an m16 only it doesn't have
the automatic or burst but that's the
whole point where you pull a trigger and
a bullet comes out like all guns the
other is I have two Walther PPQ okay one
of them fires nine-millimeter one of
them fires 40 Smith & Wesson I've three
sorry then one fires 22 for plinking and
practice it's not the same firearm just
because it looks the same that is the
least relevant piece of information
as it relates to a firearm so okay I
want people to think about this
particular point yes I want them to
think there's always this question of
saying well isn't more today
having more mass murders we're having
more problem with these guns but before
the automatic weapons ban was passed
before this all up in Spanish passed
before we got into a society that cared
less about conservative principles and
more about the cultural and moral
relativism they all agree there was less
mass murders less mass shootings back
then so we have more laws we have more
restrictions so is the difference not
the amount of guns that we have or the
amount of people with guns it's the
question of who's behind the gun and
actually pulling the trigger and that's
never addressed that entire list that he
gave you about how do we prevent these I
understand that's more of that's more of
a philosophical exercise be sure the
truth is they're lying there isn't
increased it's true it does it falls
apart when you pass the surface right no
you're absolutely right okay any other
thing I want you to come in on this the
hate loophole on a second and here's
something these people do this a lot
because like you said they're in
positions of power right and they want
you in the dark as much as possible
that's not a conspiracy when he says
hate loophole this is the first I've
heard of it absolutely it's amazing
reason one that says it's really a race
card or gender card you can use that to
say everyone else used it I'm allowed to
tell people to hate you
yes of your race and your religion way
because of the way that's textbook use
you're 52 were straight white excellent
how does not how to do percent white
would you 23andme him yeah no idea I did
how dare you
Democrats have been trying to pass these
bills they hate loophole when I looked
into a little more that would make it
illegal to own or purchase a firearm if
you've been convicted of a misdemeanor
hate crime so that's important because
right now if you're convicted of a
violent crime or an actual felony
obviously you cannot purchase a firearm
you have those laws what is a
misdemeanor hate crime what would you
have to do to get charged with it okay
so here's a specific example in looking
it up some there were these students at
a University of Connecticut okay
they were goofing off and and by the way
not condoning these actions so let's be
clear of course they were yelling
increasingly offensive words back and
forth it was like remember the penis
game when you were kid yes you say you
said penis penis penis
penis penis it's not really a challenge
because I'm a host and so bill no one
here is going to blame me but that was a
game we used to play I know women are
saying what would you say we're very
stupid we played a circle game we're
similar looks in the circle for some
reason I'm allowed to hit him yes right
everybody agrees to them unless you get
your finger through the hole I'm in the
clan apparently one of those two and
then I used to play the penis game as a
kid which is where you would have to say
penis increasingly louder in a public
space to see you know who would be more
more readily charged with a sex crime
the game at stake was your permanent
record so the kids were doing this but
they were doing a variation from what I
understand offensive words back and
forth some other students film them
saying the n-word yeah not saying you
should yell the n-word of course not
they were charged with a misdemeanor
hate crime so just saying a slur not
even anyone and you could lose your
second Amendment rights your god-given
right to protect your house and I'm
imagine that when you're a kid and by
the way penis could also the penis game
below if you've never played the penis
game okay I'm not saying that to try and
be shocking it was a very common game in
high school let me know if you played it
because now that could be a hate crime
if you say it around someone who's
gender fluid and they could be really
upset I need rigor 20 years down the
line there's a robber at your house and
you don't have to 357 next to your
bedside because you mentioned male
genitalia across the bathroom from
someone who had male genitalia but
claimed they were a woman thanks Pete
but exactly we could all be found guilty
of that crime just by singing of our
favorite rap song we've gone through
this with all those different words like
just saying the word itself is what
you're saying is wrong here by the way
we've said this so many times there is
no such thing as hate speech there is no
such thing as a hate crime
I don't tend to commit crime in a loving
manner the right nalty shouldn't be
different because I thought about you
differently in my head when I killed you
yeah the end result is that you're dead
and I do recommend you look up the hate
loophole and and see the cases that the
action make it is startling that they
believe people people have to believe
that folks should lose your second
Amendment rights yeah and one of the
interesting is when we were going
through that story notice how it was
unstated what the skin color was of the
exact it was it was think about it if if
the skin color had been anything other
than white or most certainly had been
african-american or black it would have
been no story there would have been no
story
would have been simply oh that's
certainly okay so again it's not just
the words that they're being said it's
who's saying them and the outer
characteristics of them again judging a
skin color and not by content so it's
not the words themselves it's who's
saying the words people don't know this
like oh you know we need background
checks okay this is why we used to do
the hash tag gift the gun we should
bring it back anyone who's ever
purchased a firearm legally knows you
get a background check yeah yeah every
time what happens I just watched some
some film I don't remember what it was
oh it's that show Messiah terrible show
by the way on Netflix and guys looking
to buy a gun and just goes yes I would
like to buy a gun it gives him a fake ID
we're clear and it look like I mean the
guy goes fine to me and just hands in a
bunch of its not sure that happens
you're usually there for a half hour you
have to check a bunch of boxes for some
reason you have to check Caucasian as
well as not Latino which is weird to me
it's very weird to me about the first
check did the both we just want to make
sure you're really not Latino like
you're not like Latino like Elizabeth
Warren is Native American what is this
on the questionnaire there's actually a
place where you can put here how much
percentage in Native American you are
and though it is close to nine digits
like you can decimal point and then a
lot of that's Darren ah skis next film
sequel climate change let's go to
climate change Pete but gig this is so
funny man he supported a o'seas green
new deal we're gonna get a wiki now
which I don't even know how if you you
can go back and watch that video where I
read the entire green new deal on camera
at City Pages like your if you bought a
used car your car fax is longer than the
green new deal yeah not a lot of
substance and not only that but feet but
gig went as far to while we're talking
about the moderate claim that the the
climate change was a big cause of the
Syrian war and that if you eat
hamburgers or straws you are part of the
problem don't take my word for it and
migration crises are increasing because
of things like droughts and fires that
are accelerated by the problems in our
climate there are some evidence that
this contributed for example I really
think about it mostly through the
perspective of guilt you know from using
a straw to eating a burger am i part of
the problem oh really well
Pete problem because I think every one
of the things ever closed Oh chief look
I think this is so stupid what it is sod
get hot and he was like god it's
terribly hot over here I need to start
killing people no he didn't he also
forgets one very important things jobs
don't always equal peace in some
cultures they do but these guys hate us
yeah Isis is fighting them they're funny
they're always going to be fighting it's
not because of the weather yeah okay
thinks that we now have Isis and people
are being burned alive in cages because
the one point to change Fahrenheit
exacerbated so LeMay knees mailmen
that's nothing I learned I didn't
realize that the Middle East was
apparently not a desert then America
caused the Middle East to become a
desert because our flower a huge impact
on the environment yeah that's what
created Isis well if I didn't weigh we
did a Greta's way effectively syria
would be ferngully they'd be growing
through it would be great
aside from terrorism that's in abundance
collard greens are not a cultural staple
for you for good reason we dare we did
sweetheart death okay there let's go to
abortion this is another one again the
moderate candidate but let me know what
you think but gig made waves for saying
that there's no place by the way for
pro-life democrats in the party yeah so
that was that's what people know if i'm
allowed of maybe off-color they think
maybe it's a one-off no it's not because
he also refuses to place any limit on
abortion at all including infanticide
and this isn't a radical position in the
democratic party we'll talk about that
with alan dershowitz a little to make
america's favorite lawyer after this
because someone that must be conflicted
if they consider themselves pro-abortion
pro-choice but they think there are
limits there is no place for you in the
democratic party it's actually far more
moderate because nearly every major
republican considers there to be
exceptions for rape or incest right
Democrats none not a single candidate
outside of Tulsi Gabbard would name a
point where you should stop the abortion
so before watching I'm about to show you
even the pro-choice group the Guttmacher
Institute they say that most late term
abortions this is important on TV x are
because of health of the mother
so when but he goes on to say in this
clip late term abortions mean there's
some kind of terrible health problem
according to his own sources he's
flat-out lying now you see the clip from
pro-life people like me was that you
know there's a lot of controversy with
governor north um and what it means and
what what time a woman should be able to
have an abortion I just wanted you to
clarify because I found that statement
to be pretty radical well I'm just
pointing to the fact that different
people will interpret their own moral
lights and for that matter interpret
scripture differently commercial birth
abortion is something that was coming up
in in but like I said governor Northam
it was a huge controversy when he was
running for right all right yeah I think
here comes a and Democrats in a lot of
pro-life democrats in the country want
to know exactly where your line is
because you won't be the president if
you win right but my point is that it
shouldn't be up to a government official
to draw the line it should be up to the
woman who's anybody seriously think
that's what these cases were about yes
if you're if this is a late-term
situation then by definition it's one
where a woman was expecting to carry the
pregnancy to term then she gets the most
perhaps devastating news of her life
talking about families that that may
have picked out a name may be assembling
a crib and they learn something
excruciating and are faced with this
terrible choice uh
and i don't know what to tell them
morally about what they should do
she's trying to give him rope to pull
his lifeboat so here you go here's a
rope here's a life exactly and she just
didn't like hey what do you think what
do you think as if the cackling weren't
enough now i got a deal with your mic
pops it's just it's just it's like
they're out scooping each other so this
is completely untrue it's not only
untrue by the source but let me let me
let me give you something a thought
exercise here okay we know that from the
Guttmacher Institute that's not the case
for the vast majority of late term
abortions they're zone
no time where a late-term abortion is
medically necessary period ever but do
you really buy that do you really buy
that for a second this does this is a
gross disservice to women who have
miscarriages or women who want to have
children there are birth complications
in them because if a woman actually had
the room painted and a crib up and she's
had a housewarming party a baby shower
and they've done a whole gender reveal
which I guess is also hate speech now
maybe you won't be able to buy the ar-15
after that I have no idea according to
Pete but kick-butt do you really think
that this mom is the kind of mom who's
going to abort that baby at eight or
nine months if there is a point zero
five percent chance of that baby living
that mother of course is going to go
through with the birth because to them
going through the process of birth is a
small price to pay I'm not saying it's a
small price to pay but to them even for
the possibility that it is baby this
human being could be brought into the
world do you really even believe he's
trying to pay a hypothetical scenario to
tug on your heartstrings let's use it a
mom paints the paints the walls blue
it's going to be a boy the mom's been
taking prenatal vitamins so mom is not a
Planned Parenthood activist the mom
actually wants to have this baby the
moms got in a head ultrasounds the mom
has already named the baby and the
doctor says the baby's doing well and
all of a sudden there's a complication
where this baby may or may not make it
like a Tim Tebow at eight months or nine
months and you think that mom goes oh
well get the forceps really no really
it's just amazing to me the dishonesty
and the fact that he wouldn't just take
the layup and say well of course I'm
against infanticide yeah that's the easy
one right of course you can say that he
said morrel at the end of it morally I
don't know what to tell them how about
not killing a jailbreak is there any
clear moral line that we can draw I
suspect fine if we have disagreements
down the line on what week 20 week 25
week 30 can we just say that at the very
end when doctors say it's almost never
medically necessary to have an abortion
can we just say that that's the moral
line we have to be really clear so
people know what if it's what if it said
incest silber's that's not what we're
talking about we are talking about a
baby at seven eight nine months there is
no debate at this point people say well
it's a nuanced issue it's not nuanced at
all that this baby could live outside of
the womb right right babies are born all
the time I think it was either me or my
brother was born premature one of us was
taken to get out one of us couldn't be
pulled out I don't know
but the point is I don't remember what
the point is no the point is no kill
your child about a seven eight month old
baby yeah that is still alive but there
is a strong chance that this baby
doesn't make it and so you make a
decision to stop the heart yeah we are
talking about a scenario where there's a
beating heart there's a live baby and
because there's a chance it may not make
it a doctor and a woman are stopping the
heart rent of that seven eight month old
baby and the statistics the research
according to bud Kings own sources show
us it is never medically necessary that
is unequivocal it's not nuanced that is
murder
yeah that is murder and I believe that a
doctor who willingly does that should be
charged with murder yeah and if you
happen to be in Virginia if you make
that decision and the baby comes out we
have tape of them saying this is what
you should be allowed to do you should
make a decision where they're gonna let
this baby live or die
yeah that is remarkable that's not
taking it out of context that's alright
would you have to get anything anything
yeah so definitely Peters of moderate I
was on the fence but now I'm so when
people say moderate okay if you compare
them to Bernie Sanders again the guy who
honeymoon in the USSR the guy who's that
are 90 percent tax rate is okay alright
I understand it but remember they used
to say Barack Obama was sort of leading
us towards socialism Pete but cake is so
far they left abroad he's not he's well
beyond the passing lane he's just passed
the median in a ditch okay is to the
left of Barack Obama he would be the
furthest left president that we've ever
had in the history of this country but
unfortunately because we are comparing
him now to radical leftist socialists
the guy who supports infanticide the guy
who wants mandated government health
care the guy who wants to take away
semi-automatic weapons even if you
happen to have used a naughty word at
some point is seen as a moderate
candidate Pete but gig that sniveling
little mouth always open at the fair
worm is being presented as a moderate
somebody say the worm oh my god
back come on dude he's so relatable oh
okay
Wow all right alan dershowitz after this
someone shoot him yeah hello hey do you
guys have black rifle copy oh I was just
not again not today is that no I heard I
heard you so it's gotten acidity this
it's nice but it's subtle
I wouldn't say quite citrus but
[Music]
Saskatoon berry says that that's that's
a no so it's a no I've heard of the
coffee what I choose not to support a
brand that takes part in the military
industrial complex and the needless wars
overseas that support an inherently
patriarchal system that you're probably
a fan of even though you're some pencil
Mac Chicken Hawk who's never fought a
day in his life but your uncle at
Thanksgiving told you rah rah America
this is how we do things do I have that
about right Todd black rifle coffee go
to black rifle coffee calm slash Crowder
today black rifle coffee you've heard of
them probably quite a bit they're a
veteran owned company and a portion of
the profits go to veteran causes that's
great glad to hear it most important
thing is they make fantastic coffee if
you've got a black rifle coffee dot-com
slash Crowder you get 20% off your first
order if you're not a coffee nerd well
it's a very well priced and it's
high-quality if you are a coffee nerd
you can do no better at the price point
I'm a coffee nerd we use this actually
in the espresso machine here at the
office black rifle coffee calm slash
Crowder great coffee they have the balls
to sponsor this show we're really glad
that were in a partnership with them but
overcoming BRCC
that's the abbreviation
[Music]
I mean ma'am
I mean 0:15 just walked out in those two
space and then brian Stelter this is
bizarre he closed the door
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't know what they're saying in that
song at all I mean I have no idea I
don't and I also don't know I don't
understand I still don't understand that
beanie but we've already been over that
all right our next guest no stranger to
controversy people I feel like with
especially with a lot of people who
might watch the show who are who are
younger who weren't necessarily as
involved in the political process
they know the name but they don't know
everything that he sort of played a role
in a huge part of American history he is
of course a lawyer former Harvard Law
Professor he has a new book out I want
to make sure I get this right guilt by
association which provides a pretty
in-depth analysis of some of the
accusations brought against him by these
alleged Jeffrey Epstein victims one of
them is Virginia I don't know how to
pronounce her her Virginia Roberts
career it sounds it sounds like a cheese
that I would mispronounce yeah but he
was also of course a part of President
Donald Trump's defense team amidst amid
the impeachment saga you can follow him
on the Twitter at Allen dirt mr. Alan
Dershowitz how are you sir well thank
you but it's guilt by accusation I get
that wrong again I keep saying
Association all right and you can get it
for a buck 95 on Kindle and it's really
worth reading because the accusation
against me by a woman I never met could
happen to you could happen to your
brother your sister your child so you
should read guilt by accusation I do I
do get accused quite a bit by women I've
never met but they're not as grave it's
just you're a prick and I say well you
know the evidence we have to weigh it
but before we get to that so it is it
guilt by accusation tolerant on you guys
right
did you do the audiobook I did and the
Kindle is there so you can read it or
hear it in any format you want how long
does it take you to do an audiobook like
that because it's not a short read it's
a day usually a day starting at 9:00 and
go about 5:00 I read pretty quickly and
I don't make that many mistakes so it
goes pretty fast but you know my phone
rings and I have to take pauses and
clients on death row clients who are up
for a long prison terms they have a
right to call me at any time so I don't
turn off my phone hey quick question
this is just totally when you get your
phone and it rings do you ever answer is
it ever Gloria Allred because I imagine
that would be a fight for the ages well
lo Gloria and I are friends I like
admire her I think she does great job
when she when she represents people who
are justly accusing other people and she
basically told me that she didn't
believe the accusation against me so I
think she is one of the people who
really can distinguish true accusations
from false accusations many feminists
have been on my side because they see
false accusers really hurting the
movement terribly and that's what
happened my accuser she was put up to it
by her lawyers they saw a real pot of
gold at the end of the rainbow and now
I'm suing the lawyers and suing her and
I want to see her in prison because she
filed false affidavits knowing they were
false affidavits right and people who
make false accusations against people
they never met should go to prison
people who make false accusations that
are matters of degree well I don't think
he can I consented maybe I did maybe I
didn't know they they they are making an
honest mistake right but people who
deliberately and willfully sit down and
say I'm going to accuse somebody I never
met because I can make a lot of money
people like that or to go to jail okay
Wow and I want to circle back to that so
Gloria Allred fair to say in your
favorites and your five favorites on the
iPhone we get it but let me ask you
controversial figure obviously you've
been a lifelong liberal Democrat from
from what you said on shows I want to
make sure that people are clear on that
because some people confuse your
defensive trump as you being a lifelong
Republican so as a lifelong Democrat you
decided you opted to help defend
President Trump here why for people who
may not necessarily know but it is it is
very compelling for people to hear for
the same reason that I helped defend
President Bill Clinton I testified in
his behalf I consulted with his legal
team I wrote a book about it I wrote our
beds about it I don't believe
impeachment should be used for partisan
purposes I also defended the rights of
Richard Nixon even though I supported
his impeachment I thought he was being
treated unfairly by some prosecutors and
so I jumped in to defend his rights to
from me I always defend the Constitution
Hillary Clinton's been elected president
and she were impeached on grounds of
abuse of power I would have been there
defending her as well so
I said in my speak in front of the
Senate I'm here on behalf of a principal
I'm here because I love my country I
love the Constitution and I don't want
to see the Constitution turned into a
partisan weapon in which impeachment can
be used against any president when the
House of Representatives is under the
control of the opposite party which is
what would have happened that President
Trump is removed from office
and I think there are some
misconceptions here I think the key one
that we often hear is this you're
talking around a trial with no witness
when they talk about the impeachment
saga this most people have no idea what
went on in the house
right right how many witnesses do we
have when we talk about the house was it
was at 17 or was that night it was at 17
or 18 including shift I've also heard 19
but a lot of people think no witness has
ever any point and that's just flat-out
wrong it's flat-out wrong number one
number two there shouldn't have been any
witnesses in the Senate for a very
obvious reason there was no impeachable
crime charge let me give you an example
let's assume you were accused of
miscegenation having sex with a woman of
the opposite race which of course is a
crime in many states you'd go into court
immediately and say hey it's
unconstitutional and they would say but
witnesses we need witnesses no no no you
don't get witnesses if you charge
somebody with an unconstitutional crime
you don't get to call witnesses if you
charge a president with unimpeachable
non impeachable offenses right you have
to first reach the threshold is it an
impeachable offense if we can prove it
then if you can prove it you get to call
witnesses but if even if you proved it
it wouldn't be an impeachable offense
obviously abuse of power is not an
impeachable offense obstruction of
Congress is not an featural offense you
don't get the call witnesses what would
constitute an illegal one not a factual
what would constitute an impeachable
offense because a lot of other people on
the other side well I don't say other
said because again you're a lifelong
Democrat have argued that these were
impeachable offenses I absolutely don't
think they are but what would you say
passes that threshold Richard Nixon very
clearly Richard Nixon trying to get
elected president voters in the public
interest Adam self elected president
obstructed justice bribed witnesses paid
hush money destroyed evidence all of
those things with crimes high crimes
perfect case for impeachment the only
case for impeachment in American history
Andrew Johnson shouldn't have been
impeached Bill Clinton shouldn't have
been impeached and
Donald Trump shouldn't have been
impeached but Richard Nixon should have
been impeached anybody who commits a
high crime or a misdemeanor anybody who
commits treason or bribery should be
impeached but we have an F cases like
that in our history but the frame is
rejected broad open-ended criteria like
abuse of power 40 of our presidents have
been accused of abusing their power by
political opponents so we want to make
every president subject to impeachment
if the house is under the control of the
opposite party that's what I was
fighting against right and what would
constitute I guess up but you said high
crimes misdemeanors what would perjury
constitute because I mean I've talked
about Bill well Bill Clinton so that's
why it has to be that was a low crime
not a high crime was perjury of a
private life not perjury about something
that involved governance had he
committed perjury involving governance
that would be an impeachable offense or
extortion or a wide variety of crimes
but give me an example of mystery
Alexander Hamilton when he was Secretary
of Treasury and therefore subject to
impeachment had an affair with a woman
he was married and she was married those
were both felonies under existing law
with serious punishments but he wasn't
impeached and then the he was extorted
and then the extortionist said I'm gonna
say to you paid money to me out of
Treasury funds how'd he paid the money
out of Treasury funds that would have
been a high crime but he didn't so he
wasn't impeached that he was one of the
people who wrote about impeachment
during the framing generation right yeah
I do think it is important for people to
look at the the founding documents look
at the framers at what they considered
to be impeachable and what they
specifically excluded a lot of people
don't really brush up on that you going
on there were a lot of conversations
here there was a lot of back-and-forth
where they said okay this yes is
acceptable that is not and I think we
have held right under the the latter
category and that's what the Democrats
failed to understand right the framers
excluded maladministration which was one
of the criteria for impeachment under
English law because Madison the father
Constitution said that would be too
open-ended with turns into a British
parliamentary democracy where the
president serves at the pleasure of the
legislature so he rejected that and he
rejected that he also rejected
implicitly abuse of power obstruction of
Congress malpractice all of
a open-ended criteria that framers did
not want to govern impeachment under the
Constitution that's the argument I made
on the floor of the Senate many senators
agreed with me and then of course the
Democrats and CNN went on a rampage and
claimed that I said president can commit
any crime he wants as long as he wants
to be arrested you know it wants to be
elected it was as if I had said the
following this is a good example it's as
if I had said the following I don't
believe this this is false
I don't believe a president can commit
any crime in order to get elected and
then CNN excluded the first part right
and just said a president can do
anything he wants do you think that was
deliberate really this is my question
likes it very different okay this is a
very different context here because you
appear and seen in quite a bit and you
know they would consider themselves
friendly to you for a long time
conservatives I didn't consider doke
okay so is it awkward I feel like with
with Stelter and Cuomo like are you
still can you still like ring them up or
are you persona non grata because you
used to hang out I am it pretty much
persona non grata since I started
defending the rights of the president
but no I have accused them deliberately
and willfully of doctoring my interview
what do I mean by doctoring well they
edited but they edited in a way to
suggest the opposite of what I said
right I said if President commits any
crime he can be impeached they took that
out and they said I said if a president
commits any crime
he can't be impeached that's not just
editing that's doctoring right and
that's what CNN did and MSNBC did it and
some of the other networks did it and
then the members of Congress of the
managers quoted CNN and MSNBC and made
me say things that were exactly the
opposite of what I said exactly yeah and
they are so good at doctoring I blame
Sanjay Gupta when you have a guy on
staff and that's all he does that's what
he's looking to do I don't want to move
back to the to the Epstein case into
this uh Virginia how do I pronounce her
last name by the way
goo Frey goo Frey Virginia Roberts
that's what I'm gonna go with
um I don't think we're so concerned
about the name there before I move on to
that though you did write an article an
op-ed sorry in the hill I believe where
you talked about some some of your
friends at Martha's Vineyard that
they've demanded now do I have this
right trigger warning so they can be
assured to know that they won't
encounter you or your ideas this is this
in the entirety of Martha's Vineyard no
but we have had a group on Martha's
Vineyard probably thirty couples that we
used to socialize with and many of them
now refuse to have anything to do with
me why don't you just wrote me an
incredibly self-righteous letter saying
I could no longer be in your society see
because I know the most boring guy on
the face of the earth
what a blessing I had to be polite to
him right here it's because my wife and
his wife got along and they were friends
but I was so boring when I got the
letter saying you didn't want to be my
Society up and down and Cheer right but
people on Martha's Vineyard have refused
to be associated with us and they want
to know where I'm going to be so they
say we had a friend who had a daughter
having up her son having a wedding
mm-hmm a wedding party and we were of
course close friends but so was another
couple and the other couple said no you
have to make a choice if you invite Alan
and his wife to we're not so you're a
real-life you're a real-life Larry David
where you just put the Mogga hat on the
seat next to you so that people would
people and leave the restaurant all you
have to do is defend the most
controversial president in modern
American history it's a trade off I
would go for the beanie as a court of
Lackey right here would final question
and then we're gonna go to a web
extended here after a quick break did
you get that same kind of backlash when
you defended people like you know OJ
Simpson
Epstein Harvey Weinstein Mike Tyson no
nothing like it in those instances
people said we don't like what you're
doing with Trump they say we don't like
who you are we don't like who
you are and it was very personal in the
other cases well we wish you didn't do
it but we still like you but we don't
like you now and we don't like who you
are what you've become what have I
become
I've been a civil libertarian all my
life I've never deviated from my
principles I would be doing the same
thing if Hillary if Hillary had been
elected president I would be a very
happy man today because I supported her
and be because they try to impeach her
and I would defend her and they would
build a statue of me on Martha's
Vineyard finally you know of Martha's
Vineyard making exactly the same
arguments I'm making today what
hypocrisy part of me believes that a
part of me believe that you're saying
that publicly because you don't want to
get whacked but I understand that I
appreciate a stay safe though the book
is we're gonna come back after this to
the web extent of the book is of course
guilt by accusation not association to a
lenders on the twitter for those who are
not mud club members this is going to be
after the break more with Alan
Dershowitz
[Music]
my little mug Club daily content from
bladder with Crowder $99 a year 69 for
students veterans and active military
subscribe now as louder with Crowder
comm slash mug club nada with prouder
shop comm is now selling baseball team
in red blue and ash get yours at ladder
with quite a shop comm today
[Music]
I can't swim that's called the when I
was 3 years old and I jumped off the
high dive and I forgot that arm floaties
on and oh very painful yeah cuz you you
don't shoot up back to the surface like
you normally would shoot up shoulders
first you go yeah very uncomfortable
and I almost drowned with one of those
30 pills because it tips you over
doesn't tip you back people who have
experienced this this close call with
death from their floaty belt at Seaway
pool and st. Lambert's know what it is
of which I speak everyone else sorry
Islanders which there's a long extended
view available about Epstein and the
sexers all that stuff so next week some
big shows coming your way as well I
think we have Rudy Giuliani in the show
next Thursday or Celsius that should be
about everything in college so he just
insults things by saying something that
sounds like it's not an insult but as
meant as an insult and one's like well
he must be smart prestigious like funny
that's not so much an adjective that's
just a that's just a noun custodian what
do you have a problem with custodians
they are the backbone of society mm-hm
them and teachers so I want to talk
about something we were just talking
about hate hate loopholes earlier today
with the gun laws and I do encourage all
of you look up hate loophole and I want
you to read the leftist sources and how
they believe it should be closed and
what they believe should constitute a
hate crime misdemeanor don't read
conservative sources just read the case
the actual cases themselves you can find
them it's alarming and and that sort of
combined with I was just re watching
Silicon Valley recently if anyone else
there watches I think it's one of the
best comedies in in the last decade it's
a bit of a memory trigger I realized for
the same reason I hate these hate
loopholes of the disgust is what I hate
so much about the left in comedy today
we can say entertainment and culture at
large but let's let's kind of use
comedies a jumping-off point in Silicon
Valley there's
character Russ Hanneman hilarious one of
the funniest characters that I can think
of in a modern sitcom it is making a
joke about how his Russian mail-order
bride had some ideas regarding Jews he
said something like she is some she s
MIG is regarding Jews some good some bad
that was the joke now sitting there
laughing and it's based on it is you
know contextually it's tough for me to
repeat it right now but it's it's
basically a joke about anti-semitism
right and obviously they have Jewish
people who work on the show right they
have Jewish people backing the show
producing the show and they're
comfortable creating that kind of comedy
so the joke itself is anti-semitic
ish but it's a joke about someone being
blatantly anti-semitic and I think that
context is really important because the
reason that they're comfortable creating
these Jewish producers and actors is for
the same reason that people were
comfortable with Don Rickles making
jokes about everybody regardless of race
or ethnicity or gender or really I mean
if you think most of them didn't even
make sense
like Muhammad Ali is here look get
punched in the face he goes huh huh he
goes huh what what what what what what
he says what but you're willing really
you know it's Don Rickles done but it's
the same it's for the same reason that
we weren't offended by Don Rickles back
in the day it's for the same reason that
that friends for example especially guy
friends out there we're talking about
this earlier the penis game friends make
fun of other guys mom's you know that
quarter black Karen it's a common thing
and it's it's because you know that
people don't really mean it you know
that the people in Silicon Valley are
not actually anti-semitic you know that
Don Rickles when he's roasting Muhammad
Ali hates blacks about as much as he
hates alcoholics when he's roasting Dean
Martin which is to say not at all when
you make fun of someone's mother for
women who don't understand this because
we say the most filthy depraved things
you can say about someone's mother
that's what guys do you mean under there
are two mothers guys you can back me up
on this if your wife is listening if
you're listening in the car it's less
they make you shut it off forevermore
okay there are two mothers we all know
this right there's the real mother who's
a lovely lady who you have respect for
when you treat politely when you see her
and then there's the imaginary mother to
whom you do unspeakable things on
principle just because you want to get
under your friend's skin the reason that
you can make those jokes and I say
deliberately is because it's a safe
place because you know intent there's
nothing more unfun than a guy makes a
mom joke and someone else makes a mom
joke another woman you know show cerebal
palsey because we're doing that you know
I don't actually want to hurt your
feelings and insult your mother again
the intent behind Silicon Valley is not
to spread anti-semitism okay it's not to
do any of those things it's just to try
and interact with people and sometimes
we interact with people in a way that
might be offensive to some but the point
is it was fine back in the day and it
was fine when you watch Silicon Valley
in certain contexts people are free and
open to explore they should be the
creative space that is comedy and
something that's really important the
reason we often do this and sometimes
comedy goes too far is because unlike a
lot of arts
I shouldn't say unlike a lot of arts but
I think sometimes people give a pass to
music or they give a pass to I don't
know it could be poets I have no idea
but a lot of times for some reason
people think Oh a comedian all of a
sudden means it why cuz there's no
backup band there's no bass there's no
drummer it's just a guy talking into a
microphone and so you assume that this
must be a hundred percent true or
authentic and I think that's why
comedies are real lightning rod now why
people care about politically correct
culture in comedy let me tell you this
they don't give a free pass to comedy
but sometimes it's just as just as
similar to artists I'm trying to say art
of comedians or artists but any other
art you know painting doodling what are
the hell it is I don't know what the
term artist means anymore are you a dick
are you self-important you're an artist
we get it but all comedy to some degree
all of it almost without exception comes
from pain every single bit think about
this every Joker bit that you've heard I
want you to go through this thought
experiment right now and find the pain
in the jokes louis c.k obviously if you
go to bill burr obviously these are
obvious ones if you go to Jerry Seinfeld
the pain comes from observing things in
the mundane that irritate them the same
reason Curb Your Enthusiasm is so funny
to so many people Larry David gets upset
at the smallest things and that causes
him some degree of pain let's go back to
the most basic joke there is what's the
first joke that almost everybody hears
when they're a kid or tells what why did
the chicken cross the road
right so why do the chicken cross the
road I don't know to get to the other
side the pain is you the pain is to get
to either side stupid yours
idiot it is it your expense comedy
always comes at the expense of someone
there's something some idea there's some
kind of sting there's a kernel of ouch
and what the left wants to do is make
that impossible we're talking about this
like as it relates to guns right hate
loopholes and we've seen people my
friend Mike worden candidate lost before
Human Rights Tribunal for making a joke
about a about a make-a-wish kid in
Canada who didn't die and he's been
fined for violating human rights in
making a joke about the kid not dying
that's what hate speech laws lead to the
left wants to make and I wish I know I'm
speaking broadly there are some
exceptions got it just none of them are
running for the Democratic presidential
nomination and all of them support these
kinds of laws or of course every
mainstream leftist Channel take Samantha
may take Trevor Noah take Young Turks
now support some kind of a speech loss
the point is they want to make a culture
an atmosphere where we can be creative
and we can laugh again impossible when
not only do they accuse everybody of
racism but they also don't have any
proof of racism and even in the case
where there are people who are very
clearly very vehemently anti-racist as
you see on this show or as you see with
other programs whether it's silly you
take your pick
they're always in the doghouse Dave
Chappelle was in the dog house at one
point they want to accuse everyone of
being racist everyone being homophobic
and they want you to believe that
somehow comedy what it's always been is
a secret racist dog whistle they want
you to believe that there's racism
around every corner why because it
removes that safety of us giving the
benefit of the doubt to most people so
that we can enjoy our interactions and
not be offended in other words at one
point in this country like we're talking
about with Don Rickles or whoever I'm
just using it as in this country the
baseline right it was not that everyone
was a racist or that everyone was a
homophobe at one point the baseline was
that most people telling a joke
particularly in a setting like comedy
club or at a roast or we're not doing it
out of hate the baseline was we presumed
that these are jokes we presume we
started off the jumping off point these
are likely generally decent
people who aren't hateful and now that's
been turned into racism around every
corner everyone is a racist or a sexist
or a homophobe and now it's well on a
second what if the guy is gay what if
the guy's black well okay now you're a
trans folk now you're gender-fluid folk
now you're a phantom paraplegic foe but
just keep the list keeps getting on
everyone needs to check their privilege
in some way and by the way that guy on
stage at a comedy club is telling a joke
regarding race therefore he must be a
Nazi that is the jumping off point now
right it's you notice right there's a
lot more racism than you think that's
what people want you to think right now
there's no race than you think racism is
there's a lot we just been ignorant to
it
you need to be more aware you guys need
to stop it that guy that comedian means
it that guy making a joke with his
friends that guy making a joke about
your mother means it he's a rapist no
and that's what happens we remove the
safety ironically we talk about safe
spaces we remove the safety in trying to
create all of these safe spaces for
people who are offended by everything
we've removed the benefit of the doubt
from not only performers and public
figures but now as you see with hate
loopholes speech loopholes and laws that
are proposed and supported by current
Democratic nominees we've removed the
benefit of the doubt from not only
performers but everyone in our
day-to-day lives and that's how you have
leftist liberals progressives at the
dinner table with your family who get
offended and and sometimes there's a
disconnect you know sometimes you're not
going I know we push buttons on this
show but how many times have you
recently had an interaction where
someone is offended about what you said
and that happens to everyone listening
out there pretty much everyone if you're
not currently running for the president
United States on the platform the
Democratic Party this you know an
example you might have an interaction
where someone might be offended and
again what I'm talking about behind
day-to-day interaction not something
where you're telling a joke where you
might be dancing on the line
but how often does this happen right you
have an interaction you couldn't even
compute as remotely offensive wouldn't
even enter into your mental equation and
it sets somebody oft said somebody why
is there that disconnect this is really
what I've been trying to examine why it
bothers me so much this is because
most of us are still living most decent
people are still living in a world where
we give the general benefit of the doubt
to people if they make a joke if they
express an opinion even something that
we disagree with right we might just say
as a conservative hold on a second what
what what did you mean when you said
that right there and of course the left
today when you look at these proposed
laws and you look at the canceled
culture and I think it's sort of
simplified but it really is an important
point they want to remove any benefit of
the doubt which is ironic to me because
I think that we all believe is
conservatives gonna talk about this with
Dennis Prager that human beings are
flawed selfish sinful in nature whereas
the left wants us to believe that all
people and centralized governments are
inherently morally altruistic but if
everyone is inherently morally good
that's the only way socialism can work
the other ways socialism can work is if
Pete Buttkicker Bernie Sanders anyone
who actually grabs those reigns is
inherently good and not prone to the
human condition of being selfish and
sinful if people are not all inherently
morally good right you never trust this
much of your life to a few central
figureheads in the government so the
left looks at the world through a lens
of everyone is basically good but we
don't then they also want to create an
atmosphere of there's also racism sexism
homophobia around every corner and
that's how you know that it's a
political tool you're bothered by it I'm
bothered by it why it's a political tool
and a lot of us aren't able to put our
finger on it that's how you know it's
being used to selectively silence voices
and what I'm concerned about here is is
not just that not what leftist want you
to say because none of us really care
but the culture of self-censorship that
I see emerging I'm not talking about the
First Amendment
I'm talking about something that
everyone out there needs to be aware of
and you can control a culture of
self-censorship is more concerning than
just the First Amendment a lot of what
we run into okay they're not they're
really not First Amendment issues but
it's really a bully pulpit culture
people use this term cancel culture it's
not it's a bully culture and it's
designed to create a country where
everyone says I want to make this joke
but I can't say that or you know England
you know when I actually have an opinion
when it comes to affirmative action but
okay I can't say it you cover your mouth
and you stay quiet here's what I want
you to do this week
an exercise for self-improvement this is
an exercise for societal improvement I
went out there to walk forward like
soldiers and I know this will propagate
me bend not violent soldiers let's be
clear Hill to Diane was was just
allegorical here's what I want you to do
no more covering of your mouth now if
you granite exception if you're an
actual racist if you're an actual sexist
and by that I mean if you believe that
people are inferior exclusively because
of their race or because of their sex
and you want some kind of a white ethno
state or any F no state you should
probably cover your mouth a little bit
more okay I'm not talking to you shut
this off I don't want you listening but
to everyone else I want you this week to
choose to no longer cover your mouth to
choose to stop walking on eggshells now
don't choose to offend but if you have
something that you want to say and
you're worried about people reacting I
want you to check your intent and if
your intent is not malicious say it say
what you were going to say regardless of
who it offends I want you to say it I
don't want this I want speaking and if
someone is offended follow up ask them
why and start a conversation the point
is I think you will find this to be the
case those people are fewer and further
between than the media wants you to
believe so everyone else out if you know
your intent you know who you are you
know what you mean I don't want you to
cover your mouth stop with the
self-censorship that's not what we do
here that's not what we should do
that's not how progress is made progress
is not made by getting all of the masses
to self-censor and a few people in
positions of power have the right to
tell you what is and what is not okay to
say it doesn't go anywhere good so if it
seems trivial if it seems like a menial
task no it starts with you controlling
what you can and what you what can you
control check your heart check your
motive check your intent and if you know
that it's true stop self-censoring stop
being a coward and you know what you
might find yourself going through life
with a bunch of other people who aren't
self-censoring and you realize hey this
isn't half bad it's just a few people
who are running from the Democratic
nominee and they're complicit Media
pricks all right
see you next week hopefully it UPS do
the exercise no covering enough
[Music]